yeah hello and welcome to this  announcement video it's an important one  again this is a different starting time  for the European viewers for the live  show because of them yeah the difference  in time changes in europe and the u.s.  icc works on us time quite clearly edges  based in America so we will start one  hour earlier Europe times this is nine  in the evening center you ping time  still 4 p.m. eastern standard time so we  have a gap and off schedule a little bit  for the European us again this week next  week everything will be back to normal  times so make sure to tune in the link  is clickable and in the text thanks for  watching